la clientèle augmente à la stm en raison
entre autres du centre ville qui se
porte mieux on voit que depuis la levée
de l'interdiction du télétravail le 15
novembre et depuis la rentrée scolaire
ars en septembre que l'acheteur petit à
petit les clients reviennent dans le
réseau pour la semaine du 29 novembre
dernier il y a eu en tout autobus-métro
565000 déplacement soit 61 % de
l'achalandage pour la même période en
2010 neuf dans les dernières semaines on
a vu que les stations de métro du
centre-ville ont connu la plus forte
hausse d'achalandage justement parce que
les télétravailleurs reviennent petit à
petit peu à petit peu au centre-ville la
pandémie surtout au début a fait fuir
les usagers du transport en commun
vraiment moins au début en fait pas du
tout la première année mais le messie
calmer les angoisses là depuis l'été
2001 je pense que ça j'ai recommencé
sans problème 160 sans crainte vraiment
une inconnue plane cependant l'arrivée
du variant au micron qui pourrait
affecter l'achalandage il ya aussi et ça
c'est nouveau les nouvelles directives
du gouvernement du québec qui encourage
maintenant le retour du télétravail mais
la stm demeure optimiste si la situation
reste relativement stable on prévoit que
l'achalandage devrait atteindre 75 à 90
% de notre achalandage prépandémique à
l'automne 2022 l'autorité régionale de
transport métropolitain la rtm vient
d'ailleurs de mettre en place tout
nouveau système de tarif flexible qui
tient compte justement des habitudes de
déplacements des usagers en ces terres
du télétravail issigeac bissonnet radio
canada montréal